[Music]
and you look I have to say uh yeah you
always you looking always look nice but
you look particularly nice they look
very sharp well I am mmm I respect you
and I the first guest after 20 years
specifically that's very nice to say but
you do York you have a great suit that's
right sure thank you I'm going with dark
suits of late and I'm gonna tell you why
I have realized that how do I put this
my right armpit is is an enthusiastic
sweater and my left armpit not so much
you wait you you're saying it you have
your armpit sweat asymmetrically as
you're saying yeah exactly
they're they don't they don't say you
know was there a moment where this was
clear to you that this is a real problem
I have photographic evidence from the
Teen Choice Awards which uh I don't mean
to brag but I did win best hissy fit
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm gonna brag I want best hissy-fit
waiting swords and and and they give you
the trophy which is a surfboard which is
which is great on a mantle and and so
I'm celebrating with my mantle I have a
photo
you know photo this is you holding up
the surfboard right this is you at the
and this is an actual yeah oh my god
you're right look at that
yeah oh my god
it's almost like you're you knew it was
happening and you're making all the
worst gestures in the world I had no
idea was happening you're like I got all
these are some guard over there suddenly
suddenly my friend is like hey your
armpits blowing up on Twitter okay what
okay alright that's the world we live
prescription antiperspirant duh there's
no such thing as a bell no I was gonna
say oh I wish I wish